yeah welcome to this video playing Faro
mundomartim and the first two moves I
easy we are in the King's Bench a two
week okay so what about this yeah let's
do this and go d5 attack a center yeah
that is an interesting structure that I
have to admit and never understand from
both sides i really don't get it if i if
i get this kind of thing with wide i
have problems and with black usually
it's the same scenario always have
problems with maintaining the center or
if I'm like I never get to get so much
against it so let's see what happens my
idea is to put t4 under pressure here
night f5 possibly queen to be sick so
let's start with the move and go from
there also f6 is actually an interesting
IDM what about f6 assistant isn't this
good attacking a sender if he takes
Queen takes oh no no I'm winning the
pawn here right how is he not losing the
pond now even Bishop takes what's
feasible but this is really just the
pawn
it's opposite colored bishops but okay
maybe this this is cc6 porn is quite
clearly something to worry about so
let's put it here that um I have played
possibly against f2 so let that make
some sense if I play rook f6 now he
might take their rookie 6 Ruby 6 Bishop
g5 rookie aid rook e1 king of seven so
that's not enough I can play the move
then yeah so King up I guess
yeah that's nice a point is upon but
still it's not easy to get anywhere as
the pawns are not able biood would love
to get them get them rolling I wonder if
rupee aid they're probably not that's no
way to get them get them going okay you
might see try to double that maybe I
should just go to the six that could be
a good place for the Qing er you can go
a form and still still I like to like to
put it on d6 thats that's quite a good
good spot for it a 5 I thought even
bishop the aid as possible but now I
have to say it is a bit of a bit of a
weird idea what about a 5 a-5 TX bishop
jakes
hmm Jared some counter play it really is
I have no goods good place to put the
bishop maybe look f4f why no that's
totally wrong I have to keep c7 covered
maybe a five Bishop c7 and then like
rook f7 and regroup now I underestimated
the pawn pushes
now that was said was just barely played
shouldn't have gone for that kicking to
d6 it's not a bad idea it just just
badly timed just has to go Rupe see one
now it gets a bit awkward
he didn't go for that okay it's quite
strange to be honest okay let's use that
tempo here Oh is he going for 86 or what
I don't get it don't quite get it
let's cover that prophylactically let's
say I wrote before I had rope before we
didn't take a look before here and then
looked 8 to f7 to cover the bishop that
that was that was just stupid maybe I
know maybe he allows me to correct that
mistake nope doesn't so what now can
read if i can trade one roof that would
be nice so let's get one look of him so
that he cannot invade anymore
so maybe bishop over 26 yeah I have
spoiled quite a bit of my advantage
already but of course it's still it's
still upon so we can I can try with some
justification okay check
let's see like g4 or something something
else getting this getting an idea like
Bishop Jim one end would be nice but
it's not easy to do it's difficult to
imagine without pushing the corn a
little bit at least so let's go deform
active
okay maybe maybe play it simple Luke
trade might be a draw but what can you
do
I c-can't Bishop to see ate all of the
time it's maybe
what okay let's just continue and see
what happens Bishop d3 I tried to go
with my bishop oh he allows the time
we're going to do three ok i will do
that I don't don't know if that is a
good idea really King the 2 i'm going
over with the bishop oops ah and now he
gets that oh no what is stupid stupid
play now he just gets the point you
would ever check how I thought I can
check him I can't draw offered check
draw offered game draw oh how stupid and
you can you play now I missed a mr. ton
of chances he of course yeah here this
is a clear 1i just go look at four and
that's that's pretty much that's a huge
improvement him I just wanted to protect
c7 um prophylactically but this is just
much better he has to to cover that
passively and then I'm putting the rope
here actively on on this and then e5
it's pretty simple actually probably
wins quite easily yeah he we just gave
me that that big sent upon his only hope
were the opposite colored opposite
College of Bishops wed which at the end
were rather decisive point yeah I really
have to go Rugare for it was a huge huge
mistake and now it's already not that
great he gets all those trades and check
yeah from Roxy seven is a stupid idea
it's really a draw after that I should
do this this is not bad blocking the
seventh-ranked and maybe getting like
this and d3 yet still very good from
like his King is so outside and it was I
don't know that was a stupid idea I
thought my king is still quite active
but he can probably actually not so sure
this is a very easy draw or not yeah it
probably is it stays on t1 and okay this
is very bad but let's just say I avoid
that up do this this this and now we can
move yet and draw no that's not a draw
I'm sorry I can't I take 2-3 here
this is I wonder if this is a positional
draw actually like this and here this is
a draw why is he smiling me I i I'm I'm
tubes buying him okay that is not that
is also not necessary so here and he
just stays I don't I don't see how I'm
doing this whenever i go here he goes h4
and that really is a draw yeah it's a
draw not nothing to be done okay well
thanks for watching